- All right. It's always
nice to end the hour
with something that could
possibly make you feel good.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
It is no secret that
nurses do angels' work.
We all know that, especially
by now, they take care of us
physically and often, emotionally as well.
But one Atlanta nurse has gone
above and beyond even that.
When her patient passed away,
she decided to adopt the woman's dog.
It's been a match made in heaven
and we have this super kind
frontline worker dialed in now,
with her newest pup,
Jacks, watching on WSB-TV.
What's up, Kim? How're you doing?
- Hi, Kelly.
(applause)
- Hi. Oh, well, tell us more about
how Jacks came into your life.
- So, I actually took care of
his former owner in the ICU.
I got to know her family
when they flew in town,
and they were extremely sweet.
They told me the dog had
unfortunately been in the pound
for about a week because
they did not live local.
And when she got sick,
that's where he was taken.
So as soon as I found that out,
I told them that I would go pick him up
without even knowing
what kind of dog he was.
And when I got there, I saw him,
and I instantly fell in love
and he's been mine ever since.
- I love this story.
So how is Jacks adapting to his new life?
- He's doing great.
Like, he fits right into my life.
He's spunky and he's fun.
My other dog, Hailey,
absolutely adores him
most of the time.
Sometimes he's a little bit
much, but he's a lot of fun.
He loves to travel with me.
- Aw, that's awesome.
I love dogs. Thank you so much, Kim.
Jacks is super cute.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
Thank you as well for being a nurse.
Thank you so much for that.
But that's not all.
Our season-long partner, Pilot Pen,
makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor truly unstoppable people,
and just remarkable people just like you.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars. How's that sound?
(applause)
- Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much.
I feel incredibly blessed.
Thank you so much. That's insane.
I, I feel so lucky. Thank you.
- Well, it's, we can't do
anything to possibly repay
like, the sacrifice you
nurses have made for us
you doctors, everybody,
and, and care like y'all.
We, I've always appreciated it,
but now we get it even more.
So thank you so much for what you do,
and thank you to all our guests today,
the incomparable and
amazing Cher and Renée Rapp.
From my house to yours, y'all,
I hope you have a great day.
And if it's not, well try and change that.